robin hood's merry band of men he was
taking money from the rich and giving it
to the poor that was his specialty
was it really the rich he was taking
money from or was he taking money from
the
government who was taxing people too
much
our economic systems are set up like
that to make a minority
rich and a majority poor but if 500 000
people in america can make a million
dollars don't you think
one million people can make a million
dollars no you don't believe that
no not for one minute there's a reason
that bezos is the richest man in the
world
and the walmart family is the richest in
the world amazon doesn't have
competition
tell me one thing that's overpriced on
amazon they want
profit because that's their reward i get
that you want to paint me
as an advocate of the government i'm not
thank god man because we're on the same
page
who's against rich people bernie i'll
freaking vote for this guy suppose we
had here come
a different economic arrangement you
know who writes the laws in this country
it's the lobbyist
blaming the government is an american
pastime it's more popular than baseball
[Music]
valuetainment giving values contagious
this world are entrepreneurs we gain no
value to haters how they run homie look
what i become
i'm the one
[Music]
so my guest today is richard wolf he's
written over 12 books he's got a new one
that comes out i will put the link below
he was a
he is a professor and has taught
economics at the university of
massachusetts amherst
he's taught economics at yale city
university new york university of utah
university paris
he got his bachelor's uh magna [ __ ] laude
in history from harvard in 1963
masters from stanford phd from yale
and uh he has an issue with those who
love capitalism so i figured we bring
him on and see if we can have a friendly
debate here about capitalism and
socialism so richard
thanks for being a guest on
valuetainment it's my pleasure thanks
for inviting me
so richard i mean short name for richard
is rich
why does rich hate rich people what is
it with you rich i'm trying to figure
you out
actually i don't hate rich people some
of my best friends are rich people
if you know if you go to harvard and
yale you're surrounded by rich people
even if i didn't want to have them
as friends i would have had a little
choice in those places
no it's for me the problem is not the
individual the problem is the system
and so i i don't hate rich people at all
i feel kind of sad for them
because they've worked many cases quite
hard to get to be rich
imagining that that's what life is about
and then they get very disappointed
along the way and after three martinis
they tell me all about
so you you think they're working too
hard and they're not enjoying life and
because of that you know
they would be much happier if they work
less that's what you think
among other things yeah i think they'd
be happier if not only if they worked
less but if the kind of work they did
and the kind of relationships they have
with other people in that work were
different
they'd be an awful lot happier and i'm
that's not just my opinion that's what
they've told me
so so let me ask you this a lot of times
in life like for myself obviously we
were just talking about the painting
behind me
many times when you go back and you see
somebody how they form their opinions
there is a certain trail on how to get
to it right
how did you get to the opinions and
beliefs that you have today if you can
go back and talk about
i was raised in a family here's my mom
and dad this is what happened to me at
this age i kind of want to know the
underlying motivation that led you to
believe in what you believe in today
well sure i can give you some of the
milestones at least as best i've been
able to make
make them out um i grew up i was born in
ohio in the midwest my father worked in
a steel factory in
youngstown ohio but when i was five
years old that we moved east
and we settled in a suburb of new york
city called new rochelle you may know it
and it was a commuter town my father
took the train into new york city every
day
uh worked like uh really hard in the
city came home in the evening
most of the people in new rochelle were
commuters
um like him and so the train took about
35 minutes to get from new rochelle
into grand central station and when i
went with my father
and very important we would pass
on this train through harlem that part
of new york city
and you know looking like as a youngster
looking out the window it was very easy
for me to see
two things one the people whose
apartments by the way were often no more
than four five
six feet from where the train passed
um i could see into their apartments
because that's where the level of the
train was
and i could see two things one that they
were very poor
and number two that they were black uh
these were very clear
signs even a little kid could figure
that out and so i
asked my father what what is that
why are those people living like that
and my father who was mostly a distant
father and didn't give me all that much
time
somehow felt that this was an important
question
and gave me a level of attention and
concern that i'm sure was the most
valuable thing about all of this
but he also explained to me that we live
in a society
which is fundamentally unfair to an
awful lot of people
and for example those poor people living
crowded in those uh
not real nice looking apartments those
are among the kinds of people that
are not well treated not given a fair
shake
in life um and i listen to him the way a
child does
about you know i went with him fairly
often he did take me how old were you at
that time when he told you this i'm
curious
i i would say i was probably nine ten
years of age very interesting yeah and
you know i i think i half understood
what he was talking about
i loved the attention and so you know
the way children do the next time we
went into new york i made sure at around
the same time to ask
a variation of the same question so that
we would have this conversation which i
very much enjoyed
and then you know as i grew older i
began to get interested in basically
understanding
you know the basic questions came to me
why are some
nations rich and other ones poor why are
some
people rich and others poor why is the
quality of life so different
new rochelle is a suburb that has very
poor
and very rich people and a good number
in between
so i was constantly reinforced in
asking that kind of question now your
your pops uh
uh who was your dad's inspiration like
if i were to ask
who was your dad's favorite president
would he would you say fdr would you say
who who was he who was somebody that he
admired and he liked
um i'm trying to think i think the first
person in this country he was an
immigrant let me
let me go back i was born in the united
states
got it neither my father nor my mother
were my father was
french and my mother was german so i
grew up speaking french and german
i only learned english when they put me
in the kindergarten and i
had to speak it uh so the first person
my father i remember speaking highly of
was franklin delano roosevelt that
person
loomed large as a political leader
who my father felt gave a damn about the
average person
did a lot of things to help people in a
very hard time the great depression
um and i remember hearing him
talk very glowingly about fdr
now when you when you think about that
when you say fdr
so for you you've had your belief system
since you were nine years old it's not
like you're somebody where you say
i used to be a republican my parents
were republicans
and i decided i realized that's not the
way to go so i
went and studied and then i became a
socialist because i met a professor
you had this belief system for 60 some
years you've had it for a long time
i've had the belief system for a long
time but i've also entertained
other belief systems partly again my
father and my mother were very
open-minded they did not want me
to be a parrot they did not want me to
parrot even their perspectives
so in my home there hangs a photograph
of my first political act which is
standing at the commuter train station
in new rochelle new york
holding a sign that read i
like ike which was actually eisenhower
in the republican race for president
and you know i had no problem doing that
with my friends
and my parents they did ask me questions
why i was doing it
but i told them why and that was my
business to determine
so they've been very good about that i
i've never felt
and i did the same with my two kids uh
it's not my job
to shape your political ideas i'm sure
some of that happens no matter what we
do
just sure of course but otherwise
um i don't think that's appropriate any
more than telling you what religious uh
affiliation you ought to have or
anything like that do your kids have the
same political beliefs as you
i don't know if they're the same in in
the way america works they'd be left of
center but they're not the same they're
not they're not as
left as you may be but they're left off
center they're left of center
my son much less left my daughter
uh closer to me how old were you the
first time you read communist manifesto
uh 16 or 17.
so did a school teacher give it or did
your pops or mom say read the book
my my father told me this is an
important book
for you to read given your interests
giving your questions
given our conversations um you know here
here you're getting something that is
very european for someone who's been
through the european
schooling uh the american system
was a continuing shock yeah fact that i
would
give an example when i was young uh my f
when i went to high school
ninth grade the first time the way high
school is set up in in new york state
my father asked me about my classes in
latin
and greek so i answered my father
there are no classes in latin and greek
in my high school
he didn't believe me he said oh you must
be mistaken
the next day he went into the school
with me
barged right into the principal's office
he was polite and all that but he said
look i want to talk to you about
latin and greek and the principal was
very nice guy the principal
he brought me in there so i of course
had to be witness to all this
uh the principal said we have never
taught greek in this high school
or at least in the years i've been the
principal uh
and we don't teach latin unless four
or more parents or four or more
sets of parents were to demand it if
or more four or more if four
or more want it we will get a part-time
teacher
to offer it my father then went around
found another three parents and i
learned latin
in school but in a class of four
students wow because there were that
only that many parents i mean my father
stopped when he got
four but that's how i learned my father
was always of the opinion
that what was offered to and expected of
american high school students
was a scandal it was not serious
he for example he gave me plato and
aristotle to read
he gave me saint augustine and thomas
aquinas
we're not counting that it had nothing
to do with that but if
he felt that an educated human being
needs exposure to these great works
and he was aghast that the high school
made no effort now let me ask you how
old were you the first time you read
wealth of nations or atlas shrug
that was college that we were in three
or four years later
um i read adam smith
basically because i had a class a
freshman class at harvard
that gave me you know a few selected
readings i don't know 30 40 pages worth
of it
i found that so intriguing and so
interesting
because it was my question why are some
nate you know why are wealthy
the wealth of nations why do some have
it some don't
it was a book that entranced me i liked
it
i learned from it i've had respect for
that work
all my life as and right to this moment
uh so that's when i encountered that and
so so when you read wealth of nations
and you read the
uh uh atlas shrug by iran both
times when you were in college did you
at that point start debating the teacher
did you kind of start defending uh
more philosophies that were more uh from
the altruism more from the karl marx
side or were you were you a debate guy
from the moment you started reading
these books or was it more just like oh
wow interesting let me see what this is
about
no i think i was more of a debater type
i wanted to
to fight but to be real honest with you
and i'm assuming that's what you want
um my teachers could not
or would not answer more and more of my
questions
as i became a sophomore and a junior
senior in college
and i could tell because these were
sometimes teachers i liked
sometimes teachers i didn't like on a
personal level
but i could see that they couldn't
answer my questions
either because they didn't know what it
was i was asking
or they knew but it was
frightening or scaring them to go into
it
i could tell in some cases which of
those it was
in others i just guessed but the level
of discomfort that my
questions would provoke made me back off
just as a
i didn't want to make these people's
lives unpleasant as i say some of these
were teachers i liked and i learned from
yeah i didn't want to be a pain in their
rear end but i could see that my
questions
put them in a very uncomfortable place
so what i did was i didn't pursue it i
would ask a question
i tried to make it word it in a way that
wasn't confrontational
and then when i got a very dissatisfying
answer or no answer at all
yeah i would literally and i mean this i
would run
to the library at the end of the class
bury myself in the library the way few
other students
did and read myself
silly trying to work out what a good
answer to that question
would have been that the teacher was
unable
or unwilling to do so the opposite
answer of yours not your answers so
meaning the answer to the question you
were asking
as if if the teacher was to answer a
question that they didn't have
you'd go try to find the answer that
they should have given that's right
okay exactly what i tried to do but to
be fair i mean
i don't want to be you know misspeak
here there were also cases where
um the teacher did give me an answer or
kind of dismissed
my question that got me even more upset
and then i went to the library to
reinforce
my sense that i had a point to make here
i had a
there was some validity to what i was
saying and then i would learn that i was
wrong in some areas right in others
but you know you get better educated if
you're driven like that if something is
really
important to you you kind of read the
article or you read the book in a
different way
uh from what you do if it's just an
assignment in a course
you're an april first baby i mean it
makes sense you know as an april fools
my dad is april 10th
and uh my former c.o.o was april the
12th and my best friend from the army is
april 9. you guys are wired
in a very interesting way i hire april
babies because i love them you know it's
interesting you say that when i was a
kid in iran
my mom and dad would put me in a bible
study in christian sunday school
and i would always get kicked out of
sunday school and because i would ask
the weird questions i said god loves us
so much why do we get bombed why do we
how many people died you know they had a
hard time with me they would say sir you
got to keep your son out of this because
he's confusing the other kids
so i was an atheist for 25 years of my
life but let's let's go back to
a part that you brought up you said your
dad was a distant father meaning he did
his best but he was a heart you know he
was a hard worker
so when you did drive up to harlem with
them you use that as an opportunity to
ask
more questions looking back did you in
did a part of your motivation come from
a place where you read a book and you
said
you know what if my dad didn't have to
work as hard as he did
i probably would have been able to spend
more time with him did you ever process
it that way or no
yes i did i was i was aware
um i was aware i don't remember whether
this happened to me this recognition
that you point to
in college or in graduate school but one
or the other
i had a very very clear sense
and i became a little bit
psychologically self-aware
i should put in parentheses my wife is a
psychotherapist
and my daughter is also a
psychotherapist beautiful
so i am surrounded by i've been tutored
in psychological
understanding for many many years by two
people who are very close to me
but in any case yes i had a sense
that my father uh as an immigrant here
in the united states
had had to work very very hard all of
his education in europe
all of his connections all of that was
gone
all of that was left behind when he came
here he really had to start
from nothing uh he worked his rear end
off
i do believe not to be dramatic that the
heart attack that finally killed him
was not unconnected to the anxieties of
making it here
to the insufficiency of money so yes i
had a personal way
of feeling that this system had not
treated my father
or my mother um very well
we were always as a family grateful that
they could leave europe and survive and
come here
and my parents had an appreciation
for the united states because it had
saved them the way many others in their
family had not been saved but having
said that
and not denying it the level of
education
and the level of work imposed on people
to even scratch out
a basic living i think it killed him and
i think it
harmed him and it made him less
productive
to this country than he could have been
if he were not treated the way he had
been
how old were you when he passed away
let me see he died in 19 31.
you oh you were 31 so you were young
when you passed away yes
way early okay i can i can see how that
can be a painful experience
but let me ask you this would you
consider yourself a hardworking man
would you say you're a hard-working
person
yes i am referred to by most of the
people who know me
as a workaholic so if you're a
workaholic
maybe because your father sounds like my
father
okay my dad uh in iran ran a manufacture
he ran up he ran nivea and max factor i
don't know if you're familiar with those
two you don't look like somebody that
puts makeup on every day but
no but i'm familiar with those brands so
my dad ran
max factor nivea and iran in u.s money
he was
making you know like comparable to a
hundred thousand dollars a month
in iran and then he went from iran when
the war happened
he died six weeks later we escaped my
mother and i and my sister we went to
germany lived at a refugee camp and then
we came out here he had
heart attacks after heart attacks and he
worked at a 99 cent store for
15 years in inglewood california okay
right right and you know how it is a
father-son relationship it sounds like
you love your father as well i had a
very good
very tilted he's still alive got the
knock on what is still with us here
uh one of the things that i saw if my
dad was born here
my dad would have been a very very
successful man but sometimes
one of the best things he did is
bringing me here so maybe your dad's
example to you is why you ended up
becoming who you are today
you know by having that work ethic being
passed down to you where you alone
yeah where you're just his legacy is
continuing through you
yep and i think that that's something
that happened
long ago and happens on very deep levels
that you're only
barely aware of and that you certainly
cannot control or at least i can't
sure but i'm not upset about it i really
like my father and i'm grateful for
all the things that he that he did for
me so so now let's go into philosophy
this was very helpful because this kind
of gave me an idea about your background
parents and and the viewer can also
get an idea about where you're at and
how you came to conclusions so
so you say why the question why are some
people i've asked this question myself
when i was a kid
but you you brought it up already three
times now so why don't we start there
why are some people rich and some people
poor
according to you well because our
systems
our economic systems are set up like
that
there is no way that a capitalist system
of the sort we have
uh could have any other outcome
than to make a minority rich and a
majority
poor i mean it's a little bit like
sort of understanding the the history of
economic systems
the major three economic systems over
the last i don't know
several thousand years at least i'm
talking now you know western europe
north america and so on
um the major three were slavery
feudalism and then capitalism
um and there's something all three of
them have in common
a small number of people sit at the top
of this society
in slavery it's the master in feudalism
it's the lord and in capitalism it's the
employer
and a vast majority of people are in the
other position
they're the serf or the slave or the
employee
and it shouldn't surprise you that if
you look at slavery the masters are rich
and powerful and the slaves
by and large are not and if you look at
feudalism
the lords are rich and powerful and by
and large the serfs
are not and we live in a capitalist
system where
by and large the employers do really
well
relatively and the employees well i'll
be nice
not so much and in order for us not to
have the split between
rich and poor whether it's on the level
of a
of a region or a nation or or
inside a small community we would have
to
confront whether the effort to overcome
the the gap between rich and poor
is a reasonable objective if you
abstract from the economic
system that basically produces those
things that's why i said at the
beginning
when you asked me the question i hate
rich people no
i know they end up like people like me
who come from modest circumstances
very hard not to conclude as you go
through life okay i
see now that there are rich people and
poor people
and it isn't hard for me to tell you
which i'd rather be
i'd rather be there than over there
but the problem is there aren't enough
there's
for everybody who feels that way to get
to that point
and it's a very sad reality that is
hard for people to come to terms with
which is why people like ayn rand can be
popular because she presents an idea
that suggests oh we could all do this
uh and you don't believe that not for
one
month gosh richard come on okay so let's
let's talk about a couple things here
that you brought up and i've watched
i've watched your debates i've watched
your uh uh different things that you've
done so you said slavery feudalism and
capitalism okay so slavery and feudalism
versus capitalism
slavery and feudalism have one uh uh
underlying uh uh difference between
capitalism because in feudalism and
slavery
you don't have a choice there are no
choices
you know they tell you what to do and
you better do it
in capitalism they tell you what to do
and you have a choice you can say screw
you i'm
leaving you i resign you know a lot of
times people think
a uh just because somebody is a ceo
there's such a powerful incredible life
that they live
and they'll never get fired but the
truth of the matter is
ceos get more get fired more often than
employees do
because every time an employee leaves a
guy or a ceo to another company and
takes the trade secrets that's a form of
being fired every time a client leaves
it's a form of being fired so you cannot
say
feudalism and slavery and compare it to
capitalism that's pretty uh
you're you know today a lot of
millennials would say richard you're
reaching that's what they would say to
you
well let me respond okay you remember
the story of robin hood
okay yes i do i've watched it many times
okay
uh let me remind you robin hood's merry
band of
men in the woods those were runaway
serfs turns out serfs had a choice
they could stay underneath the lord on
the feudal manner where they were
probably born
or they could try to break away
from that situation they could run into
the forest
and join up with robin hood they could
get beyond the reach of the lord whose
reach was usually quite limited
they could set themselves out to then
become what were called
free peasants or yeoman or small
farmers there were in fact all kinds of
options
that they had they were risky but you
know leaving your job
as a capitalist economy that's risky too
in fact having a job in capitalism is
risky
right now we've got 35 million people
who just got fired
it turns out employment is risky
slaves also by the way ran away
slaves also made revolts slaves
also carved out for themselves much
better conditions
than they had been born into through a
variety of mechanisms
the portrayal of all of them as unfree
which is the way the literature does it
and capitalism as free
strikes me as an extraordinary reach
since the vast majority of people who
are employed by a capitalist
an employer either live with that or
they're free to quit in which case their
basic
option is to go be an employee of
somebody else
as an employer which is not quite the
escape you might want to recommend
it's a choice but it's not a choice to
escape the system
because you really can't do that in most
cases
and if you were to suggest that a an
employee can go out and start his own
business
most of them really can't and many of
those who do
end up in a situation that many small
business men and women will tell you
about which is they work harder
than the people who are employees and
look
longingly at the possibility of going
back
to be an employee because however ugly
and unpleasant it was
working for yourself can be even worse
so now let's you you touch on a lot of
things so let me take them one at a time
i took
notes i'm taking notes here so you're
the professor i'm the student i'm taking
notes
all right so let's talk about robinhood
so robin hood was taking money from who
and giving it to who
he was taking money from the rich and
giving it to the poor that was he that
was his specialty
but he was was he was it really the rich
he was taking money from or was he
taking money from the
government who was taxing people too
much richard you got to tell the true
story of robin hood
in iran i watched it a few hundred times
so he wasn't taking money from the rich
he was taking money from the government
that are so noble they want to do such
good things for the people
and he was giving it to the people maybe
you and i read all the
mr robin hood's story a little bit i
watch it in farsi maybe the translation
was incorrect
i don't know i don't know either but
here's the way i read it
yeah he was against the government
because he saw the government as
in the clutches of the rich and so for
him
whether he stole from a rich traveler
going through the forest
or he had pitched battles with the
sheriff of nottingham if you remember
his arch enemy for him the distinction
between the rich people and the
politicians those rich people had in
their pocket
was a difference he didn't care much
about he would take from either one of
them or both of them
and give to the people that they
together were putting on the short end
of the state
yeah i don't if you're if you're asking
about some of the so again it goes back
to the taxation they were taxing the
hell out of the people
the government was these noble people
that eventually a greedy person comes
and abused power but if there's one part
that i get from robin hood is the
following you do need
uh laws and you do need lawyers if you
look at china back in 1984
china only had four law schools you know
the whole milton friedman argument when
he says you don't really need laws and
you know just kind of leave it alone
that argument is not going to work 100
you need you need law and you need
lawyers right
they had four law schools in 1984 and
only 2 000 lawyers
and china had to make sure they get lost
or else
the powerful businesses without some
sort of regulation and laws would abuse
other people so that part
absolutely i agree because today you're
seeing a lot of that taking place
in many industries whoever can get the
best lobbyists that can pay the most
money to people that they can control
and campaign with
they can pass a lot of the laws but when
you say the rich and the poor
i uh i sometimes wonder what direction
you go from there as far as the the
you know uh uh the the people that are
employees who cannot be rich you're
saying poor people cannot be rich
rich do you know how many people last
year filed their taxes that they made a
million dollars how many people in
america do you think filed taxes
that they made a million dollars what do
you think that number is
income what do you think i'm actually
curious to know what you think
good question no statistic in my head
comes to my mind but it's from the irs
it's a government organization that you
trust yes no no
listen you want to paint me as an
advocate of the government
i'm not that's not i i don't trust the
government i don't see the government
as an immigration thank god man because
we're on the same page there that's good
to hear
okay but how many highly classified half
a
million dollars i don't know what a
number is i actually am curious
on what you think so you and i are
having a drink together i don't know if
you drink we're having coffee hot
chocolate we're having a beer
and you're talking we're shooting the
you know what and i say richard how many
people last you made a million dollars
in taxes what would you say
four million four million people you
said
made a million dollars yeah so the way
you did the math was
330 million you did one percent little
over one percent
of the 330 million half of them can't
work because they're kids or they're
older
so working employees we have 100 we have
150 million people in america that
actually work
uh and out of 150 million that work
one percent makes around 460. one
percent makes 460.
if you know how they see you in the one
percent you make 460.
500 000 people last year filed
in their income taxes that they made
over a million dollars
500 000 it's not like it's only 18
people
it's not like it's only 62 000 people
it's 500 000 people last year made a
million dollars in america
if you and i were talking and you were
to say i climbed mount everest and i'm
the only one that did it
after 65 years old you're the only one
i'd be like oh my i could never do it
i have a hard time sometimes climbing my
office here you know three stories
i'm going crazy you climb mount everest
that's impossible
i get that argument that not everybody
can climb mount everest
but if richard 500 000 people in america
can make a million dollars
don't you think one million people can
make a million dollars don't you think
more people can make a million dollars
no you don't believe that no
not from one minute seriously yeah
what's your argument how do you argue
that part though so 500
000 richard made a million dollars last
year that's a lot of people
right but in order for there to be 500
000 people who make a million
then there have to be an awful lot of
people who make very little
which we've always had capitalism has
always
produced and reproduced vast numbers
of poor people as a system it is
very efficient in reproducing
vast poverty it might be nice to focus
on the rich at the other end but they
are relatively small in number
compared to those who really are having
a hard
time and you could i suppose
blame it on the individual that would be
very convenient for those who are rich
because then they could claim oh it's
because of me
rather than a system that assigns these
roles
but you know the master knew that the
reason he was a master
was because his father and mother were
masters
and the slave understood that he was
you're saying in the world of business
or you're saying the master who owned
slaves
the master who owned slaves okay and the
slave understood he was a slave
mostly because his mother and father
were slaves and that's how the system
reproduced the people and at the top of
capitalism there is a relatively small
class
i went to school with him for 10 years i
really do know them pretty well
and a good number of them are my friends
to this day
but that's a self-reproducing group that
does
let others in from time to time you got
to stop hanging around with harvard yale
and
stanford people you got to get out and
go to glendale community college
you you got to get out and go to some
regular people like us who are not at
your level of brilliance and
intelligence and your peers at harvard
you got to come and hang out with us a
little bit you've been hanging around
with too many elitists and powerful
people richard
some of the small people no that was
over when i was you know
when i got my phd at yale they always
looked at me
uh as somebody who must have been
dropped on the floor by his mother at an
inopportune moment when he was a baby
because he went in this other direction
you're not supposed to go
to become a critic of capitalism if you
go to harvard stanford and yale
if you're not familiar let me assure you
that my teachers
with very very few exceptions
were cheerleaders for capitalism every
time
here is this what year is this what year
is this
i i i entered harvard in 1959 and i
finished my education
at yale in 1970. that makes sense
a lot has changed in 50 years but i've
been a professor
at those and other universities ever
since
and in my humble opinion nothing has
changed
it is the same today i go around the
country i speak
every year in i don't know 20 25
college and university settings from
state schools and community colleges
all up to private universities and the
the combination of ignorance there's no
nice way to say this
the combination of ignorance about
capitalism and socialism and all these
kinds of questions
and the company the combination of that
ignorance for many
and a kind of weird
confidence in a point of view for which
they have no support at all
teaches me since these are perfectly
nice and intelligent people
that this remains a taboo topic
for most kids they do not as they go
through college
whether it's community college or
university they are not
exposed they can't be to anybody who
takes this stuff
the critique of capitalism seriously
they're just not given the opportunity
by the way half the time they invite me
it's precisely
to kind of open a little space in a
curriculum that would otherwise not
touch it
i don't know about that i think the last
i went to uh harvard uh uh
for a opm program meaning an owner
president management program it's like a
three-week program you go to
and you have to do a certain amount of
dollars per year to qualify for it so i
went to it
and it was the time where trump and
hillary were debating
okay right and so in one of the halls
that says we're opening up the debate
teachers showed up professors showed up
everybody showed up and i think i'll
just go in there
and i'll sit in the corner just to watch
to see what happens
richard 100 of people
hate it passionately
your favorite person in the world that
you have a painting on the wall right
next to you president trump
they hate it they hated president trump
and they were all like bowing down to
how amazing
you know hillary clinton was i'm talking
five six hundred people i'm just like
sitting there watching i'm like
wow this is pretty this is a guy that
voted for clinton
and this is a guy that voted on the left
and the right and he's a registered
independent today
so i'm watching these guys i'm like wow
this is pretty wild so now when i hire
people and then they come from schools
they come out of ucla if they come out
of harvard if they come out of uh
uh berkeley's obviously you know where
berkeley's at if you if they come a lot
of these schools even yale
your your the reason why a sanders was
able to get as much traction as he did
as a byproduct of the last 30 years
socialism is getting a
a a lot of uh through education and
school and a lot of socialists
are able to pass their agenda to kids
and kids are thinking about it you're
seeing that it's not like i'm the first
person that's telling you this
so well stop patrick i don't agree with
that
you don't agree with the fact that the
spirit of socialism is in universities
today
absolutely let me explain to you what i
mean first of all
i don't like hillary clinton i would
have i would not have bowed down to
hillary clinton then i wouldn't do it
now
she is for me the other side of the same
coin that mr trump is on the other side
of and i don't want that coin neither
the one side
nor the other a socialist perspective as
far as i understand it
uh has a you know finds that this
distinction between those two of them
minimal
it's not zero but it's minimal and an
excited supporter of either of them
you would not find me to be now on the
question of bernie and the interest in
quote-unquote socialism i go all over
the country i really do i interact with
these people all the time
and here's what i can tell you which may
come from you may upset you i don't know
they are not uh pro socialists whatever
they say on their polls
what they are is bitter and angry
that what they took to be the promise of
capitalism
isn't available to them they are loaded
up with debt going through their college
the quality and quantity of jobs they
can get with their ba
is worse than it's ever been they were
led to expect by their parents
by their minister by the community they
grew up in
a a set of opportunities that are fast
disappearing and they know it from
talking to one another
they feel to be blunt betrayed by
capitalism
that's what they're saying when they say
well what's wrong with socialism
because it really isn't that socialism
has captured them
or that they even know much about it
it's just it's their way of giving their
finger i agree with what's happening
i actually agree with what you just said
and i i totally agree with what you just
said but this is the part i agree with
let me explain
so you said they they're it's not that
you know how nowadays they say people
don't vote for somebody they
vote against somebody you've heard
you've heard this before you're in time
yes yes so they're bitter at capitalism
okay so now go to capitalism so now
the next question i'll be asking you is
what what is the definition of
capitalism to you because
you went straight from capitalism to
college debt
that college debt is not capitalism
college data is controlled by
the government being able to push every
debt through them to find a way to make
more money
college could be one-sixth double cost
what it is today when you got a harvard
uh university sitting on 40
billion dollars of endowment and they
took a 8.55 million dollar check from
the government just two months ago
because of coronavirus and they're
sitting on 40 billion
colleges are more expensive because of
government if you look at that
uh debt is higher due to government
they don't have to lower the interest
rates the way they are to where it is
today
giving money away constantly to bail
people out that's the
government's ties that's not a
capitalistic system
a true capitalistic system is not the
involvement of the government trying to
bail out some of these too big to fail
companies
so i'm not coming from a place of let's
go bail out another of these
big companies and let's not prevent them
from going out of business if they screw
up they should go out of business
but that's not capitalism that is a and
i'll finish up and i'll give you
uh turn it over to you that is a
interpretation
of these teachers who have jobs
making 49 grand a year 62
000 a year 82 000 a year if they're
professors or maybe higher ups
private school most teachers you know
don't make a lot of money they make
thirty six thousand forty thousand
i don't see teachers getting up saying
capitalism's awesome guys
i don't see that i see teachers for 16
years
saying how bad capitalism is and how bad
rich people are
because they're not the happiest people
in the world 16 years later these 22
year kids are like dude these rich
people suck and capitalism sucks
who's against rich people bernie i'll
freaking vote for this guy
that's how i see the processing taking
place what do you think
good i'm glad you put it that way so let
me tell you how and why i disagree
with uh with what you said um
i find it somewhere between amusing
and ironic that
the defenders of capitalism have had to
resort
particularly in recent decades to what i
take to be
a hustle uh it's like selling you
snake oil uh medicine that's going to
cure you of everything
here's the hustle here's the hospital
when you when there's unemployment in
this country
it's because the employer has fired you
when you lose your home it's because the
bank or the lender has foreclosed on you
uh so when you have a system that
periodically every four to seven years
has a crash
uh in which millions of people are
thrown out of work the instability of
capitalism stupefying
or it produces enormous inequality which
these days is also stupefied
you run the risk that people will in
fact turn
against the system that they've been
told
is what they are living in namely
capitalism
so it was a smart move hustler is a
mixed thing good and bad
it was a good hustle to say hey
given our system it's going to piss off
an awful lot of people
we need to train those people to blame
something other than the system
and the target that was chosen and this
is very old
is the government so you have this
phenomena
in america unemployed people don't blame
the employer who fired them
they blame instead the government they
find
something that they can point to that
the government
is the bad guy lying behind and causing
the nice employer to fire me or the nice
banker
to dispossess me of my home and destroy
my family and all the rest of it this
this remarkable and ain't rand is
obviously
with all of this this notion that the
government is the bad guy
which neatly avoids the question gee
why would the government be the bad guy
is that intrinsic to government
some people say yes well historically
they've been the bad guy
historically and in the present i mean
the blaming the government
is an american pastime it's more popular
than baseball
i lived in iran we said it i lived in
germany they said it
the government historically has been the
biggest bully in the world
that is that is proven now careful
it has been said by people who want the
blame
for a system failure not to go on the
system
no that's that's a bit of a hustle i
would explain what the government does
because of who controls the government
who has the predominant influence
governments do what they are pressed to
do
you know who writes the laws in this
country it's the lobbyists
and you know i hope you know that 90
percent of lobbyists come
from capitalist enterprises nobody else
can afford it
you know the big donations come from the
richest people who are enriched mostly
by big business etc etc the government
is the agent
not of all of us but of those of us who
have the ability
to shape and influence what the
government does
blaming the government is very useful to
get the a capitalist system
off the hook but i don't take that
seriously for me the government is
another arm of the system the system
works
some of its magic through private
enterprise and some of its magic through
the government's
shaping an interaction and for me
that's what socialism one of its
important
insights is to understand that the
pretense of the government
as an independent actor in the society
is mostly
phony it's false it's not it's not
what's going on
and that the change therefore can never
just be
elect tweedle dumb or elect tweedle d
clinton trump yes they're different
but in many ways they're the same i
don't know if you saw it a few years ago
nancy pelosi
was giving a talk somewhere in a college
and a student
a young man raised his hand and asked
her about socialism
and you could tell the video was right
on her she was very perplexed
and she looked at kind of befuddled took
a few extra seconds and then looked at
the young man
perfectly nicely and said i really don't
know
what you're referring to we are all
capitalists now i've seen that yeah
perfect i couldn't have said it better
myself that's exactly right
capitalism has two political parties in
the united what's your point though
what's your point with that
the point is that the government should
not be made the fall
guy it's not appropriate the government
is not an independent
not the fall guy it's not the fall guy
that's not what i'm saying let me
explain what i mean by beautiful by the
way
richard historically you cannot dispute
the fact that government's not bullied
people
i mean you can't dispute that i
understand today
some people are massive corporations
they can they can push people around
they can censor people
they can do a lot of things today and no
one's disputing that part
but but what i'm talking about is with
what you're talking about
uh you know uh the the power government
pushes around and some things they do
so earlier you said you're also not a
government guy
now you're saying it's an escape that
the capitalists use to blame it all on
government so let me ask you this
question what is the only way
i can have a monopoly with the help of
who what
is the only way i can have a monopoly
can i have a monopoly all by myself
is it possible for me to build the
business and be the biggest and have a
monopoly all
by myself or do i need someone's help
according to everything that the that
the discipline of economics has
ever argued the answer is for sure
you can do it by yourself there's no way
in the world i can do it by myself
no way in the world i can let me explain
to you why i cannot do by myself so
there's no i need a loss to be on my
side because
i need you who work for the state that
your campaign's coming up
to tell you i need you to make the
barrier to enter very very tough and
allow me to buy that company
for 17 billion dollars to put my
competition out of business
for me to own a monopoly and without
your approval
i can't have a monopoly because with
if you follow the law i get stopped i
can't make certain moves
the only way you see monopolies is with
the help of the government coming in and
saying
don't worry about it i'll help you out
let's go make this monopoly happen or
else it's not possible
it's not possible to do so let me give
you the counter argument we have two
basic laws in the united states
against monopoly okay right one is the
sherman anthony you know the story okay
those laws were fought for
by the victims of monopolies that had
come into power
independent of governmental support the
whole purpose of those laws
was to not only prevent the government
from helping
monopolies but to put the government in
the business
of breaking up the monopolies that had
formed on their own in economics
here's how the logic works so
if you look at the cost of producing a
commodity
over time the line the cost curve it's
called in economics
keeps going down it's basically the law
of
the larger the quantity of goods you
produce the cheaper each unit costs you
and that's kind of built into modern
technology sure
so if you have 500 firms competing
each one trying to capture the market
for whatever
the one that gets the jump for whatever
reason
in step one to be able to sell more
x's than the other guy will be able to
produce at
a lower cost eventually when you follow
the logic
there's one guy left the one who
produced the largest amount
therefore got it to the lowest cost
could charge the lowest price
and that would out compete all the
others monopoly
is the product of competition
the irony of by the way this is in adam
smith
not just karl marx and others the logic
of capitalism
is a competitive system that destroys
itself and that has in fact happened
and led to the opposition of other
companies
and the public who don't want to be
ripped off by this process can you can
you elaborate and define destroys itself
what does destroys itself mean like a
company
i'm competing and then i get too casual
too lazy somebody else comes and
destroys
me is that what you're saying no no no
no no this is a situation where uh
there's 500 companies producing i don't
know potato chips
right and and one of them comes across a
new kind of potato and
it goes better so he can sell more
potato chips than the next guy
because he can sell 10 million bags
instead of 2 million bags
he can produce potato chips at less per
bag
than it costs the other guys who produce
a smaller amount
so because he can produce at a lower
cost
he drops the price that swings the
demand
over to his product and away from the
others
who can't afford to match him because
they don't have the low cost
since they don't have the big uh the big
output
eventually one guy is able to get the
entire market
and he will produce at the lowest
possible price
and the lowest possible cost the others
go out of business
because at the price he charges close to
what his cost
is they can't compete and so he's left
all alone once that moment is reached
once he has no more competitors
then then he can begin to jack up the
price
because you don't have anywhere else
give me one example
give me one example of that today one
example of that today
why you want it today it's all through
history no no give it to me today
give me one example of that today
microsoft
microsoft amazon amazon doesn't have
competition and amazon charges up prices
what's expensive on amazon
amazon has driven almost everybody out
but what is expensive on amazon name me
one thing that's overpriced on amazon
richard your argument i want to give it
to you
give me one thing that's not my argument
you said eventually they raised the
price i'm just repeating what you said
tell me one thing that's overpriced on
amazon they're not they're not ready to
at that point yet they're not the only
deliverers that's just not possible
though because
right now amazon is scared shitless of
walmart
right shitless of walmart that's because
capitalism works now
my concern is the following my concern
is bezos movie
moves to dc he moves to dc that scares
me
he moves to dc he gets in the pocket of
lobbyists i'm not sitting here
you know oh my gosh dave facer's the
greatest entrepreneur i'm not what i'm
saying
my concern is is his next move
is to buy politicians to be able to
bully the other guys
that's my concern i'm not okay for that
but you cannot tell me that the prices
at walmart or
amazon are so expensive that that
doesn't make any sense because it's not
true
well i mean it depends what you mean by
expensive but i would tell you that they
also
make very careful arrangements not to
put each other
in that competitive situation they're
exactly aware of what i told you
they're aware that this is a race to see
who gets to be the one with the lowest
cost
and that whoever that is customer wins
wait a minute that's the way the game is
played
and that's how you go out of business
these companies then can get together
when they've gone down from 50 or 500 to
only six or seven
and then they work out an arrangement
the history of antitrust
is the history of the government
breaking in at those times
because like with amazon and walmart
there's a reason that that bezos is the
richest man in the world
and the walmart family is the richest in
the world they have jacked up the prices
above their oh my gosh
because they had no competition the
complete opposite
argument the argument is john doe's
market
in toledo was selling milk for 459
walmart came in and says this guy is
charging it for too much
we'll sell it to you for 359 john had to
lower to 349 to be able to compete
it's the complete opposite argument
there and that argument doesn't have
weight behind it richard it does it's
always been the history
you lower the price you drive out your
competitors
and when you have reached down to three
or four not one example of it today
there's not one example of it today
listen that's the history of the
automobile but i'm telling you today you
don't have one example of that today
one we we had a dozen but it's
overpriced
what are you buying that's overpriced
everything you buy from amazon and
walmart
is priced higher than a competitive
alternative
wood pricing what are you talking about
everything i buy on amazon is cheaper
than the other places i
buy that's why people are buying on
amazon so if you would
if you would have taken the argument the
other way around that's where i get
stuck
so here's a suggestion for you to know
that a capitalist gets stuck
the part that i get stuck is if you say
to me
well what about poor bobby that runs a
small market with seven employees
and he can't afford to pay the minimum
wage because
when uh bernie sanders went up and said
raise the minimum wage
jeff bezos to 15 an hour and you know
what jeff said
oh thank you bernie you just put out 50
of my competition i will gladly raise it
to 15
and are mr socialist thank you for
eliminating my competition
why because none of my competitors in
toledo kansas
can raise the minimum wage for 15 bucks
an hour because it's impossible
he officially put people out of business
the argument that you could have made
for me to say that makes sense
is what is that joey do that runs a
small market how do i help that guy out
him and his wife have been running that
business for six years now they're
passing on to their kids
that that's place has got my dad worked
out of 99 cents or people would come
they knew
david i once gave a talk in front of a
couple thousand people
and i kept talking about my dad david
and where do you where the 99 cent store
was on inglewood
and he says what does david look like i
said like this he says i went to david
every week it was an emotional moment
for me because it's like they wanted to
go to him
there is an argument there but there is
no argument on prices going up to the
richard
that argument doesn't have weight today
i think it always did that's why we have
not today
sure it does it's the same argument that
has existed all through the history
not today though not today where today
what is expensive today let's everything
that you buy is expensive because you
are now you're an economy that has been
monopolized now
for decades i don't know about
monopolized i don't know about
monopolized
how many competitors to amazon do you
think there are
depends on what product you're talking
about if you're talking about prime
if you're talking about in general most
people these days
are buying online from a very small
number of
general providers yeah i
like i said to you i am concerned about
amazon moving to dc
to hire the best lobbyists and pay them
the best money
to make it harder for small business
owners to compete them with the help of
the government
but you're then just jumping into the
story at a particular moment
amazon understood first it has to
destroy
all the little department stores and
everything that they've done just like
walmart
one as a deliverer the other one as a
brick and mortar okay
they did that over the last 40 years in
cooperation with the people's republic
of china
for whom they became the mass
distributor they
took care of wiping out nine
tenths of their competition now they
have a de facto monopoly
they want to and they can in many areas
raise prices above cost because they
have no
competitor but there's let me finish
there's a risk
there's a risk that people like you and
people like me
become critics and that we can reach the
victims who are overpaying
with our criticism about their operating
a monopoly
they know that how do they deal with
that
by the washington post if you're jeffrey
bezos
put yourself in a position to shape the
narrative so that you can now
get the government to do what
capitalists
always want the government to do namely
to reinforce
to protect and to extend whatever
their needs are and in this case it's
the need to perpetuate
a monopoly position they were able
to uh you know acquire that's what they
do
i agree so then the core issue richard
here becomes
the issue that i'm that goes even deeper
that i think about
is the issue becomes our current
election system and the model doesn't
work
if i can buy my congressman my senators
my
governors my politicians my presidents
if i can
buy them if i can buy them guess who
controls them
there's these big too big to fail
companies that can go around and push
their weight around
they can control them you're saying not
true no no i agree on
i couldn't agree more so let me ask you
this you're somebody that's well read
you've been around you you have way more
experience on this than me
what is an alternative to the model that
we have today where
politicians can't be bought how do you
fix that i'm curious
well i think you have to change the
system at the base you're not going to
change it we've tried every reform
imaginable those folks get around them
they evade them they weaken them they
repeal them
for me the fundamental issue is the way
we've organized the economy
and that goes back to the beginning of
our conversation factory
if you have a small number of people who
are employers
grabbing all the profit into their hand
and the vast majority of people are wage
earners
you've set yourself up to fail those
minorities
precisely because they are a minority
employers are a small special interest
minority group in our society
they want profit because that's their
reward i get that
so they do what's useful to that never
run a business have you ever ran a
business yes but let me just finish
so they buy politicians because that's
part of what you do
to be a successful capitalist suppose
just to answer your question
suppose the way business was organized
wasn't
hierarchical an owner a board of
directors at the top a tiny group
making all the basic decisions and
telling the vast majority
of employees where to stand where to sit
when to come where to go
and keeping the product of their labor
at the end of the day
if we didn't have that suppose we didn't
have that bifurcation
the employer and his group and the
employees
small group majority minority majority
suppose we had here it comes a different
economic
arrangement let's call it for lack of
better word
economic democracy or let's call it
worker co-op
here's the way it works everybody in an
enterprise
is equal one person one vote
we decide together what we're going to
produce
what technology we're going to use where
we're going to produce
and what we're going to do with the
output no split between
employer and employee because we the
employees
are collectively our own boss
the desire of 95
of the small businesses i've ever spoken
to is to be
my own boss here's a way for the
employees
to run the business and guess what if
the employees and the employers are the
same people
there isn't a split on what the
government is supposed to do
because if you lower your own wages to
make more profits
you're just moving your money from one
pocket to the other it's an
idiot's activity it is a no a new world
which maybe can support a government
that
genuinely respects one person one vote
instead of pretending to do that and you
and i both
know who controls the government who
controls and buys the votes
and all the rest you ever won the
business before
i've worked on several businesses i've
started two or three
i've been on boards of directors when
you started those two or three what
happened to your businesses
someone out of business some survive the
ones that survived how long did they
survive
they're still going some of them are 30
years old are they profitable or
non-profitable
well it depends on what you mean by
profit but they had net revenue and
that's how they survived
how how dare you make profit you ought
to be ashamed of yourself
richard to be making profit how dare you
make
profit off of people's back how dare you
run a profitable business oh
you ought to be ashamed of yourself mr
professor richard wolff that's how we
started patrick i don't hate rich people
i understand they're players in a system
i'm a player in the system too i breathe
the foul air
i buy goods that are made in china with
with the wrong conditions you know my
sneakers are made by children in
indonesia i get it
i try to avoid patronizing them but yeah
i don't see a problem with that that's
why that's why i'm criticism
of the system i don't want to be in it
either but but what's wrong okay let me
ask you a different question let me ask
you a different question
are you in your house are you in your uh
at a different building in your house
in my house who chose the paint uh on
your wall who chose it
my wife and i your wife and you okay who
chose the the
if i come to your house and i walk
around the sofas and the couches who
picked it
who chose it both of you what did she
pick and you didn't pick
who's a better cook you or her i
honestly i think me
okay all good what's her name by the way
harriet
harriet hello harriet anyway so so
you are a better cook than she is right
well yeah because
in my house where i grew up uh we
couldn't go in the kitchen the kitchen
was the kingdom of my mother
and only she could do anything in there
her husband my father couldn't get in
there either
she that was right i don't think that's
fair i don't think that's simple either
but you know what it does it makes the
children like my sister and i
very eager to be and work in the kids
wow
you just explain capitalism yeah you
just explained
capitalism you just explained the
structure of corporation
your mother was the chairman of the
board in the kitchen
and she told you guys you got to earn
your way to get in the kitchen
you worked your tail off to learn and
now you're better cooked than herring it
congratulations i wish she had done what
you say i wish she had said
you could earn your way but she was a
real capitalist
you weren't getting i love your mother
mother no matter
how hard you worked you weren't getting
into the chosen circle
and that is you're right that is
capitalism
you are as well though you are a
capitalist because when you cook you
said you're better cooked than your wife
so if your wife says to you
honey this not seven minutes put it for
20 minutes
are you gonna listen to her well it
depends if she has a good point to make
i'd have to take it seriously but i
would
you could consider him who's the final
decision maker of the food that you're
gonna cook
it's a consensus no it's not you're the
chairman of the board of the force
but my wife would enjoy this because she
would recognize that your need
for example to have somebody be the
chairman that's your accommodation
i understand that's how this system
works but that's why i'm against
i'm giving you a hard time but the point
i'm trying to make is the fact that
somebody needs to make the decision you
know
one night i rented out where were we
were we in yucca valley i rented this
house
and we went out and and i said guys we
got to come up with a coat of honor
we're running the sales office
and i said we got to come up with a code
of honor on how we run this office so i
read this place we go
i'm hoping we're going to finish early
so we can play some games we had
foosball table pool table
movies we go out there and we said we're
going to come out with what's got to be
written as a code
okay we're going through this and all of
a sudden one guy
phillip he says what we have to use he
says we have to use parliamentary law
100 of people have to agree on what the
code's got to be and we're sitting i'm
like okay let me allow them to make this
decision for themselves so it's like a
buy-in
let me be a this incredibly incredible
leader that brings everyone together
do you know what time we went to sleep
i'm not gonna say it i'm gonna let him
tell you
what mario what time do we go to sleep
six in the morning okay
six in the morning i had a movie for
them to watch
here's the point i'm trying to make from
my experience
from my experience my small 41 years
of living from glendale community
college guy okay
i'm a guy that's a regular guy from my
experience
someone has to be in charge to make the
decisions it's very challenging to put
it a collective someone has to be a shot
caller at the end and
typically the most hated guy right now
everybody's watching and talking about
the michael jordan documentary the last
dance
you know who's getting the most
criticism right now one guy
michael jordan why because he was the
shot caller
and a lot of people don't like that but
that's just kind of how things work when
somebody leads
so what are your thoughts i'll i'll let
you kind of uh rebuttal to that
long time ago we believed that in order
for any society to exist and function
there had to be the guy who makes the
decision and we called him
the king or the emperor or the czar
or whatever yeah and then a time came in
human history where the mass of us
got sick and tired of being the subject
having to live with the decisions made
by this clown at the top
or even worse by his you know
son or daughter who gets to be the next
clown at the top and so we said
no more monarchy no more
we were even mad occasionally and cut
their heads off as in france
with the guillotine right and people
said you can't do that there has to be
somebody at the top the one who talks to
god or whatever they thought
had to be and the rest of us look or our
ancestors looked at them
and said it doesn't have to be we could
live in a society
where we all have some say some input
we don't have to have one person
telling everybody else what to do
and the irony i thought i like that i'm
i'm glad that happened
i support that i like democracy i
support that as well what you just said
okay so here comes the argument i
don't like having the king
who isn't allowed in public society
to find his new place inside the
enterprise
where we allow him to function as the
dictator who tells
us whether we have the job or not
whether we
will work over here or over there who
takes the fruit of our labor
and decides where to sell it and what to
do with the revenue
why are we allowing kingdoms inside the
enterprise
when we have declared them unacceptable
outside
and yeah there'll be adjustments there
were adjustments when you didn't have
the king
it took us a while to learn a little bit
with all the imperfections
of how to quote-unquote govern ourselves
we will do the same
inside the enterprise since it is my
judgment
and i'm running out of time here but
it's my judgment that
what socialism really is is
not about the government that was 19th
and 20th century socialism
21st century socialism it's about the
enterprise
it's about democratizing the enterprise
getting rid of the kings that imagine
themselves
inside the enterprise and that kind of a
socialism from the bottom up
will be extremely attractive to the
people who are discovering
that capitalism has betrayed the hopes
they had felt would be satisfied by
capitalism
but isn't anymore what you just
described right there was china the last
part of what we're doing right now
is speed rounds i'm going to give you a
name tell me the first thing that comes
to your mind
i'll give you a name tell me the first
thing that comes to your mind jeff bezos
uh obscenely wealthy person
who is making individual decisions
about tens of billions of dollars that
were produced by the army of employees
he has
who ought to have some say as the rest
of us do
about what is done with that wealth it
is obscene
for one person to make those decisions
that we all have to live with
warren buffett same thing rockefeller
same thing gates same thing
carnegie same thing musk
i don't know very much about musk soros
soros pretty much the same thing karl
marx
one word insightful
insightful okay trump the product
of a system in deep trouble
bernie sanders the same reagan
a grade b actor who was a puppet for the
interests that needed to have a puppet
at that time
obama a person who promised hope and
change
and delivered neither of them biden a
very sad mistake
ayn rand not a good novelist and an even
worse
social theorist gorbachev
a sad character who tried
to hold together a disintegrating
system boris johnson
a british trump lenin
a brilliant strategist and tactician
but who tried to make a transformation
when the conditions to enable it to
happen simply
weren't there castro
like lennon like lennon by the way who
do you consider a great leader i'm
curious like who to you is a great
leader is there a name
like somebody would say something nice
about you seem too upset i want to
finish it on a
say something nice about somebody who do
you like and you admire
who do i like and who do i admire well
let's go back to marx
i learned a lot from marx i would have
i was always amazed that having
gone through the elite universities i
went through
harvard stanford and yale 10 years of my
life
in those institutions i should have
been introduced to their work not
not only marx of course but among many
important thinkers of the last 2000
years
you know and i mean i mean reading the
bible and saint augustine and aristotle
and marx
instead because my teachers
were afraid or caught up in the cold war
they
thought the important thing was to keep
me as far away from this marx character
as they could possibly do just a
footnote
in those 10 years i was never
reque and i have a phd in economics i
was never required
to read one word of marx's criticism
of capitalism that is a comment
on a failed educational system
uh and because i find marx's work so
insightful
not only not that marx didn't make
mistakes
of course he did etc etc but as
thinkers go you could do a lot worse and
with very few
would you get as much powerful insight
into society as you get from him so i'm
an admirer
and the only reason i accept the label
marxist is not because i'm some blinded
follower who's uncritical
it's just i want to affirm what was
denied to me
by an educational system that wants to
present itself as the best in the world
and isn't even close
uh richard well by the way i recommend
communist manifesto to a lot of people i
think when people read it they even
become bigger capitalists that's the
great thing so that's why i recommend
them reading a book
but uh richard where can people find you
i know you got a podcast going on and if
you want to tell us about your latest
book before we wrap up
right my latest book is an answer to
millions of questions that are sent to
us what is socialism inspire new
generation in america
who never learned what it was and are
smart enough to realize
that now that they're interested they
would like to learn what exactly is it
because it's not one thing it's their
different interpretations
the thing has changed over the last 100
years you need to learn it and i wrote a
short book
called understanding socialism to meet
that demand
i produce with a group a regular weekly
radio and television program it's called
economic update if you're interested in
it
you can find out where the radio and the
tv carry it
but every program uh is put up on
youtube you just go to youtube
slash democracy at work
and that's where you'll find it the
democracy at work refers to what we've
finished up talking about converting the
enterprise into a democratic institution
instead of the hierarchical top down
that it has been
we're going to leave the link below both
to your show as well as your book
richard i have
really enjoyed our conversation today
thank you so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
my appreciation also for you really i
appreciate that you do what you do
that that you do it in the way you do
and that we can have a conversation with
and without agreement
and that's what what real friendship and
intellectual seriousness
ought to be about i appreciate that
thank you have a wonderful day
you too you know a lot of people ask me
questions they say pat how do you choose
your guests how do you come up with your
guests do you agree with every guest you
choose obviously after today's guests
and the last week's guests i had
with slavoj who's a communist we don't
agree philosophically
but today's guess today's interview was
one of my favorites i've ever done
before i want to hear your thoughts
comment below
also if you watch this interview and you
enjoyed it i have two other videos i
want you to watch
one of them is with the communist slavo
zizek and the other one is a video i did
10 reasons why this guy i love
capitalism if you've not seen it you got
to watch it
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care
bye
[Music]
you